[Music]
you have magic how's it going everybody
it's Warren and Disney plus just
released their quick a little teaser
trailer for their announcement of pre
sign up for Disney Plus originally only
people who attended the d23 event or
people who were signed up for Disney's
movie rewards program could pre-ordered
Disney Plus but now it is open to the
public now a lot of people are really
wondering what exactly is going to be on
Disney Plus for Marvel and there's
actually going to be a lot more than you
think and if you're a true Marvel fan
the movies and shows that are coming to
Disney Plus for Marvel will get you
super excited so I'm going to go ahead
and break it all down in this video
quick reminder that I'm giving away
another Xbox one or ps4 winners toys all
you have to do to enter the giveaway is
be subscribed to my channel like this
video and comment below with your
favorite superhero or a villain I'll be
picking a winner at five hundred and
fifty thousand subscribers so obviously
a vast majority of Disney movies are
going to be streamable on Disney Plus
but specifically with Marvel there are a
lot of exciting things coming up now
obviously we know about the new Marvel
Disney Plus shows that have been
announced for phase four and phase five
and obviously most of the MCM movies and
most of the Marvel movies will be on
Disney Plus at some point in time but
let's start with the shows that you
probably didn't know we're going to be
on Disney Plus for example we have this
screenshot of movies and shows for
Marvel that are going to be on Disney
Plus and if you take a look there's a
lot of unexpected and unannounced Marvel
shows and if you grew up watching Marvel
cartoons on Saturday morning this is
super exciting for you
we have Spider Woman the original
spider-man spider-man and his amazing
friends the original x-men series Iron
Man and of course on the side there you
can see the Fantastic Four now these
were the shows that really got me into
Marvel I read some comics as a kid there
was a comic book shop right next to my
house but I always remember watching
these shows especially the x-men and
spider-man so it's super awesome that
these are going to be available to watch
on Disney Plus and if you take a look at
the middle section there you can see
some Marvel shows that have already
aired or have been canceled
well now you can watch these shows once
the
Plus comes out and as you can see we
have agents of shield Marvel's runaways
agent Carter the Inhumans and assembling
a universe which is going to be sort of
a behind the scenes of the MCU so all of
the old Marvel shows that everybody used
to watch that are really good and
everybody would love to see again of
course are going to be on Disney Plus as
well and then of course if you look at
the very top even though they're cut off
we can tell what these Marvel movies are
from the top left we have Avengers
Infinity Ward than we have Iron Man 3
guardians of the galaxy the first
Avengers film black panther and it looks
like Captain America so right away when
Disney Plus comes out we are going to
have an insane amount of Marvel content
and more is going to come because
they're not going to have every single
movie from Marvel on there originally
but they will eventually and this is
really exciting but this is just the old
stuff then we have all of the new
original shows coming to Disney Plus
that directly connect to the MCU now
most of you know the new shows that are
coming to Disney Plus but there have
been some new ones announced recently so
for the new ones we have Falcon and the
Winter Soldier
Wanda envisioned Loki then we have a
Marvel
what if series then we have Hawkeye and
recently announced our a Miss Marvel
series a she-hulk series and a Moon
Knight series with the last three moon
night she-hulk and a Miss Marvel being
announced at the d23 event so all of
these shows are brand new original shows
that will be in the MCU so as you can
see a lot of exciting things are coming
with the Disney Plus streaming service
and now you can pre-order the service by
going to Disney Plus calm those who
pre-order it will get first access to it
it's $6.99 a month or 60 $9.99 for the
entire year so if you are interested in
all of these shows and movies it's
probably a good idea for you to go and
sign up for Disney Plus so let me know
in the comments below who is going to be
getting Disney Plus so they can watch
all of this Marvel content let me know
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to comment with your
favorite superhero or villain like this
video and subscribe to my channel so you
can enter my giveaway and stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof